Okay I'd like to welcome everybody to
today's education funding uh committee
meeting We are here to address these
eight bills which are bills due out on
March 20th But before we get into I'd
like to welcome Representative Lee and
Representative Matson who are subbing in
for folks that are unable to be here uh
today I don't believe you have any subs
on your side Do you represent non Yeah
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yep So welcome to
education funding Um we had these eight
bills today and I just met and
Representative Spilzer and I ran met
with Representative Luno and
Representative Damon Surprisingly I
think we're on the same page in all
these bills except one except one And
you can probably guess which one that is
But so with that we're hoping to try to
expedite things by keeping all the
discussion you know minimizing it today
maybe one person from each side and and
uh and uh moving on through these bills
What I am going to do first though I'm
going to jump on our list of bills here
and not go in numerical order but take
HB443 seeing we do have uh Steve uh
Steve Applebee here from the Department
of Education and he met with some folks
yesterday regarding that bill and I've
asked that he come here today and
explain to us what he is what kind of
message he's got from that group and
perhaps why this bill is seen as as as
needed So represent Applebee
gradu and and I think fourth or fifth
generation UNH grad So my grandfather's
pictures in the fieldhouse uh 1926
varsity football team
and I want to add on to that So when he
was looking for colleges for his
daughter where did he take her Up to
Orno
Yeah thank you Representative Vlad That
is absolutely true
uh took two of my children to Orino to
tour and my wife and I both marveled
because Orino looked like college that
we remembered when we both went to UNH
many years ago Um we have a very simple
rule in our house We will not send our
kids to a college that has dorms nicer
than our house It's it's a very simple
rule So um good thought Yeah Thank you
Um for the record Steve Applebee
director Department of Education Uh
thank you uh for having me this morning
Um so yesterday as it happened there was
a regularly scheduled meeting of the
higher education commission and we
discussed this bill at the commission
meeting as well as some of the the
questions that I received um during the
hearing some number of weeks back and um
the commission which includes the
chancellors of our public systems a
number of college presidents and several
lay members um all believe that the that
the current bill um as is they support
it with this language change to fix this
little tweak that that stray and that's
in the in the statute Uh with regard to
whether or not the commission should
continue uh there was a concern raised
by we we employ a consultant to the
higher education commission uh Dr Dick
Gustoson Some of you may know Dick He
was chancellor of our two-year system He
held my position a number of years ago
He was president of Southern New
Hampshire University many years ago Um
and Dr Gustoson reminded the commission
that we should uh with regard to their
existence we should check federal law
because there was a requirement at one
time in the federal higher ed act that
states have these commissions So we'd
like to do some research on that Um I
know uh and and the commission was not
opposed to having a discussion You know
they were not opposed to maybe they
don't need to exist anymore So uh we're
just concerned that there may be a
federal requirement and we don't want to
accidentally trip over that So um that
was the result of yesterday's meeting
Um that's my input So Representative if
you have a a look
Okay Are there any questions for
represent represent Steve Applebee Yes
Since you're calling me out so what is
your recommendation So the bill as is
and then we could take up maybe over the
summer um whether or not the commission
should even exist
Okay I think the bill as is doesn't make
sense either I don't think it's I don't
think it solves the problem you're
trying to
solve This leaves somebody in if I
understand correctly if I read the way I
read it in English this somebody two
years into their term stops coming and
you leave them on there for the last
That that is an accurate understanding
Th this this was the this was the
language that was given to me by the
attorney at the time As I as I mentioned
I don't believe that attorney is at the
governor's office any longer but
um the the problem we're trying to solve
for was a a college president who no
longer represents their college They
have left that the employment of that
college but they have not formally
resigned from the commission and their
term ends Hang on The question I'm not
talking about the term ending So they're
in the middle of their term and they
stop
coming They still cannot be removed If
I'm if I'm understanding correctly the
way this is work worded they will remain
on there until their term ends at which
point they will not be extended Is that
an accurate understanding of what the
change does and doesn't do Is that your
issue
I I I I believe so I Okay Thank you
Okay Any further discussion Represent
Luno Thanks very much Mr Chair And I'm
sorry to miss the uh the first part of
your uh your statement Um Dr Applebee
but but um who appoints the members of
the commission The executive council The
executive counsel So all right Thank you
very much Representative Billsbury Yeah
I I do think that the language of the
bill as written solves the holdover
problem but it does not address the
inactive member problem So if we were to
retain and work on it that would also
allow for you to go through the process
you were talking about this summer
Certainly would Thank you
Further disc represent fellows Yes I'm
just wondering if you can tell us like
who are who are the people who are the
categories that are appointed to this
commission Well yes Uh thank you for the
question Yes So um per statute we have a
number of statutory appointments So both
of our chancellors several of our public
college presidents for example all of
the USNH presidents and two CCS&H
presidents Uh additionally the
commissioner of education is a statutory
appointment And then we have I believe
it's six members who uh
represent private nonprofit colleges
presidents who are appointed by the
executive council We also have I believe
it's four lay members
non-ol employed individuals also
appointed by the council and then lastly
um two representatives of uh private
post-secary career schools
Further discussion representative Luno
Thank you very much Mr Chair what
Representative Spillsbury suggested I
think we would uh we would support that
direction too
So is there any further discussion with
uh Director Applebee Not seeing Thank
you very much Have a pleasant day Thank
you So I I look to
uh on this particular bill I I I look to
Representative Earth for a
recommendation I would move retain Is
there a second to retain Second Okay We
have a motion by represent and second by
represent Damon to retain HB 443 443 is
bill relative to the terms of
appointment of members on the higher
education commission Represent do you
have any further discussion No I think I
made my point Represent Damon it's been
Any further discussion from the
committee Madam clerk when you're ready
Vice Chair Spilsberry Yes Representative
Maguire yes Representative Earth yes
Representative Lee yes Representative
Colcom yes Representative Matson yes
Representative Brown yes Representative
Mheaggan yes Representative Peoples yes
Representative Luno yes Representative
Ames yes Representative Burton yes
Representative Fellows yes
Representative Damon yes Representative
Ricky yes Representative Critian yes
Representative Weinstein yes Chairman
Lad yes 18 yay za
So with that this bill is 443 is
retained in this committee Thank you
What we'll do now is just jump right to
the top of the docket here and go back
to HP 137 137 is a bill relative to
allocating excess statewide education
property tax funds for local school and
municipal
purposes And I look to Representative
Maguire for a motion Thank you Mr
Chairman I move ITL Is there a second
I'll second that We have a motion made
by Representative Maguire and second by
Represent Luno The motion is to ITL uh
HB1 137 Representative Magguire do you
have any any further discussion Uh just
that this bill goes kind of the other
way of a bill that we passed and is on
the calendar for tomorrow Is it 7:39
7:30 Yeah That
um so which had a strong recommendation
from this committee So this is kind of
the opposite So therefore it repres
nothing more to add Any further
discussion amongst the committee members
Represent Fellows Um yes I'm just going
to say that that I will vote against
ITLing this bill because I think the
state using a property tax to reduce its
obligation to fund um public schools is
a slippery slope And if we do it at all
then if if we use the statewide property
tax at all then it opens the door to
making the statewide property tax higher
and that just um can shift more money
onto the property taxpayers
Further discussion Not seeing any Madame
clerk when you're ready the motion would
be for 137 ITL And this is a bill
relative to allocating excess statewide
education property tax funds for local
school and municipal expenses purposes
Vice Chairman Spillsberry Yes
Representative Maguire Yes
Representative Earth Yes Representative
Lee Yes Representative Kolk Yes
Representative Matson Yes Representative
Brown No
Representative Mheaggan
yes Representative Peoples yes
Representative Luno yes Representative
Ames yes Representative Burton yes
Representative Fellows no
Representative Damon yes Representative
Bricky no
Representative Critian yes
Representative Weinstein yes Chairman
Lad yes
So 15 yay and three nay
Okay Will there be a minority
report Represent Fellows will write the
minority report I assume Thank you very
much Representative McGuire me Yes
Okay The final vote in that was 15 to
three So it'll appear on the regular
calendar when it shows up on on a
session date
I'm sure Swep will always give us this
type of reaction Um okay Going on down
on the list here Next bill is HB237
prohibiting the use of special education
state funds state aid funds and
differentiated aid and special education
funds on students not receiving special
education services I'm going to hand the
Thank you Mr chair Um Representative Lad
Yes I would like to make a motion of ITL
We'll second that Okay Moved by
Representative L seconded by
Representative Luno Would you like to
speak to the motion Yes Very briefly um
in the past year we had a similar bill
come before the committee and when we
did the research and looked into it
federal law does provide that monies
that are coming through IDA special
education monies may be used to assist
those students which are remedial and to
prevent them from having to go the route
of the IEP process They may also be used
for after-school activities which
involve those students with uh uh this
type of uh handicapping condition So the
federal law does provide limits in and
in in and how these funds shall be used
Uh so this bill is contrary to that
federala law or act Thank you Thank you
Representative Luna Thank you very much
Yeah I would add to that I totally
completely agree with with that But also
you know how a state particularly how
New Hampshire calculates its cost of
inadequate education you know applies to
for a school district to educate all of
its um uh students And um and obviously
these differentiated aid factors uh are
used in uh in New Hampshire as they are
in other states to um to um um uh to
make that determination So thank you
Thank you very much Representative
Fellows
Thank you Um I I support ITL of this
bill but I just do want to um say that
during the testimony one of the things
we
heard not testimony not on this bill but
I think it was on the um the
universal qualifications for education
freedom accounts that there are private
schools who have children with
disabilities which I I translated to
mean that they are coded as special ed
and that school is unable to give them
any special ed services but it sounds
like there's a possibility that they are
getting the money the differentiate
differentiated aid for those students So
that just I just want to identify that
as um something related to this issue
that we should think about
Representative Lad Yeah I'd like to tag
in what Representative Luno has
indicated regarding the different
differentiated aid This money is not
targeted money on the left hand side of
the formula We must remember that
whether it's ELLL differentiated aid for
special education or free and reduced
monies those monies go down due to the
Claremont decisions and all for the
benefit of all students in in in that
school district Secondly in talking
about the EFA program they do not
receive this portion of differentiated
aid They do not receive funding for
special education IEP
in the differentiated They do I thought
they did not
They do
They receive differentiated aid Yes
Representative Ames
Thank you
the um allocation
to an EFA account for a student who goes
to a private school may or may not
include differentiated aid just as in
the public school side based on uh elig
eligibility or identifying factors that
uh identify that person as eligible for
free or reduced or special ed aid that
has to be renewed each year In the
private setting it's a different process
It's not an IEP determination because
there's no such process as I understand
it It's a determination by a one in a
category maybe of three different
uh professionals or maybe even lay
people who have status um to make
determinations about uh the disability
of an individual is not so much as a
special ed determination So with that
with that additional
um characteristic applied to that
student then that triggers additional
money for the school and again it's not
targeted money just as has been said
that's my understanding of it you see
and I was looking at the charter schools
the way the money remains for the
sending district it doesn't go to the
charter school and services are provided
those students at the charter school via
that methodology as one of the ways to
deliver the services I was also under
the impression that the same was
occurring on this I may be wrong I I'd
have to look at that and I appreciate
Representative Damon did you want to say
anything Yes thank you I just wanted to
note
that per federal law the preferred
approach to special education is
inclusion And so in addition to the
reality that the differentiated aid is
to fund the whole district for all the
kids or to help with that funding it
simply isn't practical to separate out
exactly what might be a special ed cost
or not It it just doesn't work to do
that And we heard very clearly from DOE
that their statute and practices on this
are already very clear I think this bill
is simply unnecessary
Any further comment I would just add
maybe it's a useful analogy that when we
allocate a portion of the differentiated
aid based on free and reduced we're not
asking the money to be used to buy meals
These are ways of determining what kind
of a burden a particular district
suffers
under Okay If there are no further
comments then we can move to the uh uh
vote uh which is ITL motion on
HB237 Madam clerk chairman Spilsbury yes
Representative Magguire yes
Representative Earth yes Representative
Lee yes Representative Kolk yes
Representative Matson yes Representative
Brown yes Representative Mahagan
yes Representative Peoples yes
Representative Luno yes Representative
Yeah I mean it's okay
It's not going to change the outcome of
the vote but I don't think without
objection can we allow Representative
Burton to vote The motion was made He
was not in his chair medical treatment
Okay Then then he then he's cannot vote
on this You're going to have to No
objection I just I'm just getting the
the school nurse That's that's okay But
if you weren't here when the motion was
We we've had we've had that before I I
believe the motion was made 10 15
minutes ago I have no objections and not
counting
We we were both out getting medical
attention for Representative Burton so I
won't be voting either Okay fair All
right Fair enough I don't think it makes
much difference on this So we we we've
had votes over overturned
Yes we have Okay So I I I think there's
a consensus and I don't see any
objection to allowing Representative
Burton and Bricky to sit out Um
Representative Fellows
Um vote yes Yes
What do we do Represent Representative
Damon Yes Representative Bricky
abstaining Representative
Yes Representative Weinstein Yes
Chairman Lad Yes
16 Yay No Zero naz and two no votes
Very good And those are no votes They're
well that's what the sheet has that's
marked but it's actually just not a vote
It's not a no So the vote count is 16 to
zero
16 to zero Without objection Uh we can
place that on consent Yes Okay Agreed on
consent Thank you very much Uh back to
the next bill on the docket which is HB
354 354 is relative to alternative
certification pathways for career and
technical education instructors And I'd
like to ask Representative uh Peoples
Chair I would like to make a motion to
OTP this bill Is there a second Second
We have a motion made by represent
Peoples and second by represent Damon
The motion is OTP on HB 354 Represent
Peoples do you care to speak to your
motion Yes Um I believe that this will
give an opportunity for getting
qualified people to teach trades into
the classroom and a pathway to getting
getting them certified I think this is
uh something that we really need to
address in the state and it would help
us get the people we need in front of
the children to teach them Thank you
from the second Yes thank you I am
excited to support this bill I think it
will help us to better staff our CTE
centers perhaps with retired folks who
would be happy to teach a course here
and there and have great expertise Um so
yeah thank you Any further discussion
from the committee
Okay we have a motion on the floor on HP
354 The motion is OTP Madame clerk we're
ready when you're ready Thank you Vice
Chair Spillsberry Yes Representative
Magguire Yes Representative Earth Yes
Representative Lee Yes Representative
Kolkum Yes Representative Matson Yes
Representative Brown Yes Representative
Mheaggan
Yes Representative Peoples Yes
Representative Luno Yes Representative
Ames Yes Representative Burton Yes
Representative Fellows Yes
Representative Damon Yes Representative
Bricky Yes Representative Critan Yes
Representative Weinstein Yes Chairman L
Any objections to putting it on the exam
calendar Good Thank you Uh we're going
down to the next bill This is HB 491 We
jumped over 443 Remember we did that
first 491 is establishing a committee to
study alternative funding methods for
public education and how to reduce the
reliance on local real estate property
taxes I look to represent Spielsbury for
a motion Thank you Mr Chair I move
retain on HP491 We'll second that So we
have a motion made on 491 to retain made
by represent Spillsbury and second by
represent Luno Representative Spilspbury
do you want to speak to your motion Yes
thank you very much Uh the purpose of
this bill is to go beyond the
discussions we've had so far as a
committee in the last couple of months
We've been focusing really on how the
state will allocate funds to support
districts And this gets to the question
of where the funds come from It's an
important discussion but uh I think we
have a good understanding that this
committee can form a subcommittee to
delve into this over the balance of this
year And if we retain it then we can
decide in October whether something like
this would be useful in 26
Further discussion from represent Luno
Yes thank you very much Mr Chair Um
completely agree with uh with what
Representative Spillsberry said Um look
forward to um to these um subcommittees
or ad hoc committees to get together and
take a look at this And I would also um
direct people to uh to take a look at um
the uh the 2020 commission to study
school funding which did spend
considerable amount of time and
discussion reviewing revenue sources for
information purposes only and there's
been a number of uh studies over the
last um two decades in New Hampshire
looking at various revenue sources the
impact working with um with with ways
and means uh representative as I think
introduced us to the Lincoln Institute
and expertise um uh there particularly
on revenue sources including property
taxes but also including other ones too
and um and what the reliability is of
different sources So hopefully um
members of this ad hoc committee be able
to harvest quite a bit of information um
and move forward with that and I look
forward to participating in that effort
Further discussion from the committee
Representative Ames
just to underscore that uh this is
really important and I'm grateful to
Representative Spilsbury for putting
this forward and that we all need to
roll up our sleeves It may be a subpart
of this group I recognize that But all
of us need to roll up our sleeves and uh
and step back a pace from the from the
day-to-day arguments that we engage in
and see if we can't figure out a better
way to fund our public schools Um and
and identify funding to do that Uh we're
in too many uh there are too many dog
fights going on around the state right
now that are hurting our public schools
So let's see if we can't do better Thank
you Any further discussion on the bill
Not see any Thank you Uh clerk when
you're ready we're ready Vice Chairman
Spilsberry Yes Representative Magguire
Yes Representative Earth Yes
Representative Lee Yes Representative
Kolkcom Yes Representative Matson Yes
Representative Brown Yes Representative
Mheaggan Yes Representative Peoples yes
Representative Luno yes Representative
Ames yes Representative Burton yes
Representative Fellows yes
Representative Damon yes Representative
Ricky yes Representative Gretian yes
Representative Weinstein yes Chairman
Led yes 18 Yay Zero nay So this bill
will be retained in
committee The next bill I'm going to
jump over It's the one bill I don't
think we're all on the same page and I'm
going to do it last Uh the next billing
we discussed is going to be
656 relative to the authority of local
school districts to accept federal
grants And I look to Representative
uh Pam here
to our clerk
So I'd like to make a motion to retain
There is a second So Representative
Brown makes a motion to uh retain second
by Represent Luno Represent Brown would
your Well just briefly the origins of
this um bill um occurred because of the
mission creep we've seen with our public
schools taking on non-academic program
um topics such as social emotional
learning and that involves gathering
non-academic data from minor children um
through surveys and requests for
information some of it tied to federal
grant money So in order to have parents
understand that grant money has strings
attached that was the origin of this
bill and I'm happy that it's being
retained for further work Thank you
Would the second like to speak Sure
Thank you very much Uh I think the way
I'm I'm glad this bill is being retained
um uh but also but but also for
additional reasons too and and you know
I think it's important should um should
school boards be in the uh in the direct
line here that um that we understand
what the what the what the effect that
may have on programs in public schools
and I'm not just talking about programs
that might be politically contentious
but um but programs in special education
support for our some of our need for
some of our um kids with the with the
greatest needs And um and when we take a
look at the schoolboard laws I believe
by statute they only have to meet once
every two months Um not that any school
board meets that infrequently but I
wouldn't want to see um uh you know not
necessarily conflict with with other
statute but provisions with other
statutes um u be you know be you know
introduce an untimely uh delay in um in
in making sure um kids are receiving the
services they need That's all Thanks
Further discussion Represent Spillsbury
Yes I of course support retain And I
just wanted to make the comment that
even the prime sponsor recognized that
the bill needs some further work And
there were a variety of questions that
came up about obligations whether they
were just fin uh monetary or also in
kind and uh what about future
obligations What about private grants Uh
you know what what about unanticipated
So you know it's worth the work but we
can do that later on Further discussion
Representative Damon Thank you Mr Chair
I just want to also weigh in supporting
retaining the bill while acknowledging
that transparency in how we use taxpayer
dollars whether federal or state sourced
is obviously extremely important and
also we need it to be defined in statute
in a way that makes sense for the
operating functions of the school
district and a reasonable timeline
Further
discussion Not seeing any Madam clerk
when you're ready we're ready This would
be on 656 relative to the authority of
local school districts to accept federal
grants The motion is to retain Vice
Chairman Spilsberry Yes Representative
Maguire
Yes Representative Earth Yes
Representative Lee Yes Representative
Kolk Yes Representative Matson Yes
Representative Brown Yes Representative
Mheaggan Yes Representative Peoples Yes
Representative Luno Yes Representative
Ames Yes Representative Burton Yes
Representative Fellows Yes
Representative Damon Yes Representative
Bricky Yes Representative Critian Yes
Representative Weinstein Yes Chairman
Lad Yes 18 Yay Zero Nay
So we will retain this bill in committee
The next bill is
HB729 making an appropriation to the
Department of Education for an attorney
to recotify education
laws With that I look to Representative
Spillsbury for a motion Thank you Mr
Chair I move that we retain HB729
I'll second that So we have a motion on
the table for 729 to as the motion is to
retain This is a bill relative to uh
looking at our education laws and
recodifying and having an attorney do
that Um uh Representative Spilsbury
would you like to speak to your motion
Yes thank you I I think we all believe
that it would be a marvelous outcome to
have a recodified uh um volume of our
education laws but the question of what
this actually will entail uh is still up
in the air And I think that uh Caitlyn
Davis in in speaking before us suggested
that maybe even an RFP could be prepared
by the DOE to uh get a cost estimate
before we're asked to act So I think
it's a good bill to hold on to Thank you
And the second Thank you very much um Mr
Chair And for all those reasons um and
and you know making sure that that
whatever we do put into law for um for
um um rec to recotify the education laws
you know follows a plan that uh that
makes sense well thought out and um and
has a timeline that's uh that's
realistic and um and I think having this
committee work um on that along with the
um the department as uh as as um
director Davis has suggested uh I think
will be really productive So um so
that's why I support the um retaining
this
and I'd like just to put a a few parting
words on this Um I am one of the
sponsors of this bill and it's come
before us in the past the concept the
idea that we need to look at these laws
for education and we know we've had
conflicting law uh as we did with
representative Mooney's bill dealing
with monies for school building aid and
one place in the law said you may do
this another part of the law said you
may not do this and in the same statutes
uh and we have this conflict
of of of ter terminology or are they
co-curricular sports are they
extracurricular sports what are they Um
and so we have language which is mixed
and matched all over throughout and it
just depends upon who's presenting the
bill and who's writing that and what
attorney over in in across the street is
writing it We do need to do something
here And the idea has been to contract
that service out And we've all talked
about in the past maybe we ought to do
it with one of those attorneys that's
very familiar with education law over
there a retired individual such as a
Jeff or an Anthony or somebody that's
going to be able to do this you know as
quickly as possible But it's a huge tax
A 100 grand isn't even going to touch it
Uh so we we need to really give if we
pass a bill we have to have a little bit
more specifics within it as far as what
exactly we're looking at within this and
how it might be done in the most
efficient way working with DOE So I
agree I also support the motion to
retain
represent fellows your hands Um yes I
would just like to add to that that one
of my concerns is the when it's due that
the work needs to be completed by
September because as a retired state
employee I know that there's a limit on
the amount of
um time that you can work for the state
and without jeopardizing your retirement
You're absolutely correct The time limit
in this thing is impossible It's
impossible within a few months to get
this thing done I've been told before it
might take three years to do it properly
because you're going to be findings and
recommendations come out of it Then you
have to go back and have it come back to
the legislature for changes possibly
It's a huge huge task Um so I concur
with what you just said Represent Damon
Thank you Mr Chair I agree with all the
reasons that have been stated for
retaining it and I'd like to also add
that all of us or subcommittee whatever
looking at it that we
consider once somehow it is recodified
and accurate and consistent What are the
mechanisms to keep things up to date
Because otherwise in 10 years from then
we'll be back in the same conflicting
situation
Any further discussion on HB
729 The motion is to retain
Madam clerk
Vice Chair Spillsberry yes
Representative Maguire yes
Representative Earth yes Representative
Liber yes Representative Kolk yes
Representative Matson yes Representative
Brown yes Representative Mheaggan yes
Representative Peoples yes Yes
Representative Luno Yes Representative
Ames Yes Representative Burton Yes
Representative Fellows Yes
Representative Damon Yes Representative
Bricky Yes Representative Greten Yes
Representative Weinstein Yes Chairman
Led Yes 18 Yay Zero Nay
So with that we will be retaining uh 729
The last bill on the docket In fact this
is the last bill that this committee has
that's a House
bill And so congratulations you know and
we are going to shovel it out of here Um
and then we just await our our Senate
bills coming up I do have before we get
to the the end here just one notice for
the committee here I am going to be
working with the uh ranking uh uh
representative here and my vice chair
and we're going to be setting up some
subcommittees Subcommittees are going to
be set up in a number of areas uh that
we need to have to do some work We know
we are going to be working on the
foundation formula one We know we've got
to delve into special education how we
pay for special education how we account
for special education and and all the
software packages that are need to make
sure we're getting data that we need on
special education So that's going to be
number two There's going to be a
committee that's going to be looking at
higher education in terms of the freedom
of speech and that and other pertinent
issues which we've had addressed before
this committee in higher education I
also have one other committee going
dealing with school building aid We know
that due to the revenue picture this
year is highly likely that there may be
no and I'm just looking to our folks on
finance here It's highly likely that
funds will be approved for paying off
our tail our debt But going beyond that
you know it's questionable unless we can
come find out you know a gold mine
somewhere or oil wells out back or
something that's going to provide us
that revenue that's that's absolutely
needed slot machine
represent
Maguire that that is another way of
doing it but uh but the school building
aid is very very important I oftenimes
call that the fourth leg of the stool if
you don't have the brick and mortar I
know we're got a lot of stuff going
online and all that but if you don't
have a facility that's able to contain
and offer the proper sciences
uh chem labs and all that uh you can't
do the job And we also need buildings
which have a HVAC that have the lighting
have the sound and we know there's a
really a deficit in buildings where that
is not available to the tune of maybe 15
percentage points on achievement testing
So those are four that I'm going to
start I know there's other areas which
we have to look at We've just done some
retaining of bills here and there are
going to be other subcommittees but
those are ones that I'm going to try to
get permission to move forward even
before we've gotten those Senate bills
Once we get seven bills often times
you're told well you can't do
subcommittees until you unload those
bills Well we have some time here where
we can start looking and doing that
research and working with the education
commission of the states and other
organizations to gather information and
to contact those states or looking in
our own field here how we can best you
know look at policy that's going to be
appropriate for the the funding concerns
that we're we're encountering
Representative do you have a question I
I have a question Question So when do we
have any idea I
I'm not familiar enough with the process
So can you tell me about I'll briefly
explain that and then we want to get on
to this last bill Thank you Um the
process is that I identify for example
we may have a subcommittee with maybe
seven members or five members or
whatever number of members or we may
have a committee of the whole The
committee has the responsibility of
reporting back to the whole committee
when we gather next to take the
recommendation and move forward with
that recommendation after there's been
time in the retaining part here and
we've retained right through to next
fall and and during that time we're able
to try to do some research on these
particular bills and come forth with
either possible recommendations to move
forward with that bill or if it's not
worthy moving forward We recommend the
opposite In some cases we have found
that there's even more time needed and
we look to the interim study process
which would even take it another year of
the last year of the bienium But this
process is a process where the first
name person that I identify on that
subcommittee is the chair of that
subcommittee When you come back as we
come back as a whole I will look to that
chair to make a recommendation from the
subcommittee to the committee This
committee right here as it stands right
now it's a process that can work We've
had a number of bills have gone through
that process Uh concussion injury went
through that and we came out with
recommendations how to deal with that
And even with the new research maybe
it's time to look at that Maybe a dark
room isn't the best place for a person
that's been concussed and new medical
research is saying that and you get them
going as as as soon as you can So uh I I
I think this is a worthy process and one
of which this committee has been
designed to delve into these funding
issues and we have had a brief time to
look at some of those right now and do
through the variables which we have out
there we haven't been able to deal with
I have not yet seen a spreadsheet
represent as on on and represent Luna on
your foundation formula that's something
that has to come forward so we can get
working on that Um the same thing with
special education So yes represent
spellsbury I I think this may have been
part of your question also Um all of the
bills we
retain we are due to make a report by
November
1st OTP ITL or interim study and those
bills will all be acted on in the first
session in January
Represent McGuire Yes Thank you Mr
Chairman on behalf of Representative uh
Papovich Mhler and myself I'd like to
request that this committee not meet
April Well we will be meeting for Senate
bills So so that blows that apart But
the the other portion is I understand
the predicament that division 2 is you
know when I walked up here on Friday and
where I didn't I was doing some other
work but I walk in and division 2 is
receiving reports from DOE uh and very
much engaged they're already started
that long trip that they have and that's
not a long trip that's very short trip
they have they have to make some
powerful decisions here so then we get
in the budget and so I understand that
but the subcommittees you know I will
try to get those going and just know
that we have other people here that are
not on division two that may want to
stand in and work on some of these
subcommittees So and in the past they we
even had a special committee which some
here sat on that what was a couple years
ago We had four bills We recognized that
we didn't have all the horsepower on
education policy at the time to do that
So we we borrowed two people from from
ways and means which repres you are one
of them and and represent Spillsbury and
then we borrowed two people from finance
as well In fact the chair of finance at
that time division 2 representative Emer
came on and participated in that and
through that we had a healthy discussion
Uh we just needed a few more weeks and I
think we were getting close to that LBA
has to keep up with us and unfortunately
they can't keep up with all these
spreadsheets So that's where we are So
yeah we will be starting that
subcommittee I'll start that as soon as
I can I don't want to spin our wheels
here Represent Luno Thank you Mr Chair
And I I um um agree with you on the uh
the subcommittees I think this is a good
direction I think the the four that
you've listed off are good places to
start for this uh for this committee too
But uh obviously you know what's going
on at the federal level raises a lot of
there's a lot of unknowns going forward
and um and this committee may need to
meet um additional times to consider how
the state responds to uh to any changes
that may be um coming at the federal
level So uh so I hope the the um the
committee will remain agile enough to be
able to um to you know accommodate you
know game day sort of uh sort of changes
as um as things come up
Well as the as the goals on the field
move move uh it's harder to do that you
know that that score but yeah we will
stay engaged So what I'd like to do now
is return back because we do have folks
that are already saying they have to get
out and get ready for activities going
this afternoon The division our finance
people which we appreciate there being
on our
committee
HB549 relative to use of education
freedom account funds and religious
schools and institutions of higher
education I'll pass the gavl off to
Representative Spillsbury Thank you Mr
Chair I recognize Representative Lad to
make a motion Yes I'd like to make a
motion on 549 of ITL ITL is the motion A
second Second Second by Representative
Magcguire And Representative Lad please
speak to your motion I I would be glad
to speak from the motion but I'm not
going to speak long at all I mean we
we've talked about this issue on the
education policy committee for many many
years and we've gone through all the
court cases with Espinosa and going down
all those cases which are relevant to
this topic It's my belief that the
monies which are appropriated publicly
uh if we don't use them for the private
or the private rel religious schools we
are
discriminating and there's
constitutional issues associated with
all this and so I I I feel that the best
way to do it is do as we've done in
previous years and that's it ITL the
bill
Thank you Representative Damon
Thank you Mr Chair I will be opposing
the ITL I actually think this is a
really important
bill from a constitutional separation of
church and state point of
view This is not about opposing any
faith or any religion or the practice
thereof This in fact is about
guaranteeing people of whatever belief
system they have the opportunity to
practice those beliefs independent of
government constraints
Article 83 of New Hampshire's state
constitution clearly states quote "No
money raised by taxation shall ever be
granted or applied for the use of
schools of institutions of any religious
sector or
denomination." When we provide education
freedom about account funds to families
and they go to religious institutions
those are taxpayer dollars going to
those religious schools and I think that
is constitutionally wrong Thank you
Thank you Representative Damon Further
comment Okay Representative Ames
Uh just to concur um I think that uh
there certainly have been we all know
this uh
um decisions um all the way up to the
Supreme Court that uh
deal directly or indirectly with this
issue But uh it needs to be quickly said
they've never dealt with the New
Hampshire Constitution which uh is as
explicit as uh you one could uh ever
make a rule explicit on this question of
uh taxpayer support for religious
schools It's just categorically
prohibited the on the on the other on
the um sort of the uh national front
It's not true that the issue is done and
dealt with uh in a final way by the
Supreme Court There's another case
coming right out of our neighbor Maine
that um has uh uh received a favorable
decision favorable to the state and the
state's position is that uh um that uh
limitations prohibitions on funding to
religious schools um is necessary Um and
so uh decisions favorable to that by the
US District Court for the state of Maine
and by the second you know the second
circuit is in the second circuit So uh
it's under review So it's not done and
over with and it's a complicated issue
and like most constitutional issues um
it probably will never be done and over
with uh life goes on and uh justices
change and uh opinions change So um I
think that on the merits uh the our New
Hampshire Constitution is absolutely
correct that uh taxpayers should not be
supporting um religious education and uh
discrimination in in whatever way that
tends to favor those who uh and provide
funding to those who want a religious
educ education The uh fact of the matter
about our EFAs is that a great deal of
money is going to support religious
education and that religious education
uh flies in the face of some of our um
our standards for uh adequate education
Um the
um uh an example of that is uh is the
theory of evolution the scientific
method and so forth It is very much
embedded in our uh our standards and uh
and there are religious schools who uh
make it very clear that the uh teaching
that is provided in their school system
is from the text of the Bible and
particularly from Genesis and uh it's uh
literal and they embrace the literal not
the figurative the literal uh statements
in Genesis that essentially reject um
the evolutionary
uh truths that science has revealed So
um for all those reasons I think uh that
uh endorsing a a statute that
uh that simply endorses and implements a
underlying New Hampshire constitutional
provision is uh appropriate and I will
be voting for it
Thank you Representative Ames Further
comment
Okay Seeing none the clerk can call a
role
Chairman Spillsberry Yes Representative
Maguire Yes Representative Earth Yes
Representative Libri Yes Representative
Colcom Yes Representative Matson Yes
Representative Brown Yes Representative
Mheaggan Yes Representative Peoples Yes
Representative Luno no Representative
Ames no Representative Burton no
Representative Fellows no Representative
Damon no Representative Bricky no
Representative Critian no Representative
Weinstein no Chairman Lad yes 10 ys
eight nays So the vote being 10 uh to 8
uh Representative Lad will write the
majority report Yes And Representative
Damon the minority report
for OTP Okay You've got it the draft
that I Thank you Okay Thank you very
much to everybody I want to thank
Representative Matson and Representative
Lee for being here You know
Representative Labri when I lived up to
Bangor we had Labre Bakery had made the
best donuts that I can remember And so
maybe maybe you're somehow attached to
all that No sir but I do eat them
Representative Lad Yes maybe you said
this but uh when are the uh reports due
to you Okay these reports uh we have a
little bit of time here seeing that you
know it today being what Tuesday excuse
me Wednesday Wednesday And in order to
get them in the next calendar they'd
have to be done here in another half
hour Uh so I we're not going to go there
So uh if you could get them in to me by
the end of this week I'd appreciate that
That way then I can funnel them and get
them in the in the next calendar so they
can be put on the docket They have to be
taken up real soon here by the whole
whole uh
house So any further questions or
discussion With that we're going to
adjourn this body for today and wish
everybody have a a good afternoon We'll